[ÂM NHẠC]
>> Brian Holt: Nếu chúng ta quay lại đây, tôi sẽ nhấp vào ví dụ ở đây.
>> Brian Holt: Trước hết, phương pháp nhỏ này ở đây,
về cơ bản đây là nhật ký giao diện điều khiển cho DOM [LAUGH].
Ý tôi là, về cơ bản bạn có thể bỏ qua nó, nhưng mỗi khi tôi làm điều đó.
Nó chỉ là viết một cái gì đó ở đây.
Hãy nói về CodePen một chút.
Vì vậy, trước hết, nếu tại thời điểm này bạn chưa có tài khoản CodePen.
Tôi sẽ tiếp tục và đề nghị bạn đăng ký một.
Bạn không cần phải làm thế, nhưng một, chúng rất tuyệt vời.
Tôi yêu những người đàn ông trên CodePen, những chàng trai và cô gái mà tôi nên nói, cả nam và nữ.
Và sau đó phần thứ hai là bạn có thể fork những cái này, bạn có thể nhấp vào cái fork nhỏ này
ở đây và sau đó nó sẽ lưu vào tài khoản CodePen của bạn.
Và bạn có thể tham khảo lại những điều này sau, vì vậy tôi nghĩ nó hữu ích cho bạn.
Được rồi, chúng ta hãy xem xét ứng dụng tồi tệ nhất của
đệ quy nhưng phiên bản rất cơ bản của đệ quy.
Khó mà nói ra được.
Hãy thử và nói nhanh gấp bảy lần.
Được chứ.
Vì vậy, đệ quy cơ bản.
Nếu bạn nhìn xuống đây, bạn có thể thấy ở đây là
chỉ đăng xuất 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, phải không?
>> Brian Holt: Vì vậy, nó giống như những gì chúng tôi đã làm ở đây.
Được gọi là basicRecursion với năm và một, phải không?
Về cơ bản tôi muốn nói, số hiện tại trong một đệ quy là bao nhiêu?
Và con số tối đa tôi muốn đăng xuất ở đây là bao nhiêu, được không?
Vì vậy, dòng đầu tiên
[COUGH] >> Brian Holt: Người đầu tiên
dòng đệ quy bất kỳ.
Tôi sẽ không nói bất kỳ đệ quy nào nhưng tôi sẽ nói đó là về dòng đầu tiên của bất kỳ
đệ quy mà tôi đã viết, vì vậy tôi sẽ chỉ ngoại suy điều đó cho bạn.
Và nói rằng, nó sẽ giống như tất cả các phép đệ quy bạn viết.
Dòng đầu tiên sẽ là trường hợp cơ sở.
Trường hợp cơ bản là khi bạn ngừng đệ quy và lý do tại sao bạn viết
cuz đầu tiên nếu bạn không viết nó, bạn sẽ bị tràn ngăn xếp.
Đó là lý do tại sao bạn phải có hộp đựng cơ sở của mình và
bạn muốn nó giống như điều đó đã được xử lý rất tốt trước, như khi nào tôi dừng lại?
Vì vậy, trong trường hợp cụ thể này, tôi muốn dừng khi dòng điện lớn hơn mức tối đa,
ngay sau khi nó lớn hơn mức tối đa, nó giống như không sao, xong hãy ra khỏi đây.
Vậy đây là cái gì, được không?
Và sau đó tất cả những gì tôi sẽ làm là viết ra hiện tại là gì đối với DOM, và thế là xong.
Và sau đó, tôi sẽ tự gọi nó là basicRecursion,
đúng không? BasicRecursion đang gọi basicRecursion.
Và tôi sẽ gọi nó bằng max bởi vì tôi sẽ tiếp tục vượt qua mức tối đa đó.
Và sau đó tôi sẽ gọi (hiện tại + 1) phải không?
Vì vậy, hãy lấy cái này.
>> Brian Holt: Vì vậy, như bạn có thể tưởng tượng, vì vậy chúng tôi sẽ gọi nó đầu tiên với một phải không?
Đâu mà?
Hãy lấy màu trắng ở đây >> Brian Holt: Vì vậy
chúng tôi có màu trắng, chúng tôi đi.
Vì vậy, đầu tiên chúng tôi gọi bằng một, vì vậy đó là những gì hiện tại sẽ là và
thì nếu bạn chỉ tưởng tượng đây là một ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi gọi nó với 5,1 và sau đó nó sẽ gọi nó với 5,2, phải không?
Sau đó, nó sẽ gọi nó bằng 5, 3, rồi nó sẽ gọi nó bằng 5,
4, 5, 5, và thực tế, nó sẽ gọi nó bằng 5,
6, để tôi đặt nó ở đây, 5, 6, phải không?
Nhưng một khi nó đạt đến 6 lớn hơn 5, phải không?
Geez, tôi không thể vẽ, nhưng bạn hiểu đúng.
Đó là một dòng điện lớn hơn toán học, và tại thời điểm đó bắt đầu quay trở lại, phải không?
Và sau đó tại thời điểm đó, nó sẽ bắt đầu đi xuống ngăn xếp, phải không?
Vì vậy, nó sẽ bắt đầu xuất hiện những phiếu mua hàng này, vì vậy nó sẽ làm điều này,
nó sẽ làm điều này.
Ngay bây giờ, chúng tôi không làm bất cứ điều gì sau khi đệ quy dựa trên.
Nhưng tại thời điểm này, chúng ta có thể làm điều gì đó sau khi quyền đệ quy dựa trên quyền.
Vì vậy, bạn có thể làm mọi thứ lên và xuống ngăn xếp, phải không?
Và rồi cuối cùng bạn sẽ đến đó, và rồi khi nó kết thúc, phải không?
Đó là ý chính cơ bản ở đây.
>> Brian Holt: Vậy còn câu hỏi nào không?
Đây là một ứng dụng rất vô giá trị của đệ quy.
Điều gì đó mà bạn thực sự không nên làm.
Điều này nên được thực hiện với một vòng lặp, phải không?
Nhưng đó chỉ là để chứng minh cho bạn thấy nó dùng để làm gì hoặc nó như thế nào.
Vì vậy, hãy xem xét một ứng dụng thực tế
Trình tự Fibonacci, phải không?
Vì vậy, chúng ta hãy đưa ra một lần nữa.
Đóng đó.
>> Brian Holt: Vì vậy, nếu bạn nhìn xuống đây.
>> Brian Holt: Hầu hết chúng ta đều quen thuộc với chuỗi Fibonacci nhưng
Tôi sẽ giải thích nó.
Tôi đã hứa cái này sẽ không có mathy và nó lại có mathy, xin lỗi không xin lỗi.
Được thôi, nếu vậy
Chuỗi Fibonacci về cơ bản là hai thuật ngữ trước đó được cộng lại với nhau, phải không?
Vì vậy, 1 cộng với 1 là 2, 2 cộng với 1 là 3, 3 cộng với 2 là 5, 5 cộng với 3 là 8, đúng, v.v. và
vân vân và sau đó những con số đó bắt đầu trở nên khá lớn khi bạn
bắt đầu cao hơn và cao hơn, phải không?
Vậy cái này cộng với cái này, số hạng 18 cộng với số hạng 19 là số hạng thứ 20 phải không?
>> Brian Holt: Vì vậy, hãy xem xét thực sự bạn sẽ làm điều đó như thế nào khi sử dụng đệ quy.
Vì vậy, trước tiên hãy thảo luận về cách chúng tôi đã giải quyết bằng cách sử dụng đệ quy
trong trường hợp cụ thể này, trong khi chúng ta có thuật ngữ thứ 18
được xác định là số hạng thứ 17 cộng với số hạng thứ 16.
Vì vậy, Fibonacci được định nghĩa đệ quy bởi vì nó được định nghĩa
bằng cách sử dụng Fibonacci's, phải không?
Vì vậy, đó là lý do tại sao đệ quy có lợi cho vấn đề này.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi có Fibonacci, lấy một số và
có thể là bất kỳ số nào và sau đó điều đầu tiên chúng ta làm là gì?
Trường hợp cơ sở, phải không?
Vì vậy, nếu nó nhỏ hơn hoặc bằng hai, đó chỉ là một số nhất định.
Nó chỉ là một, phải không?
Đó là điều đã cho trong chuỗi Fibonacci như tôi đã hứa.
Tôi đoán một lưu ý nhỏ khác ở đây.
Bạn có thể làm, nếu n === 0,
hoặc n === 1, phải không?
Bởi vì tất cả những thứ đó thực sự là những thứ mà chúng ta dự đoán sẽ thấy, phải không?
Fibonacci của một tiêu cực không thực sự có nhiều ý nghĩa.
Ít nhất thì nó không với tôi.
Tôi không biết nó làm gì.
Tuy nhiên, với trường hợp cơ bản của bạn là, bạn muốn khá tích cực vì điều gì sẽ xảy ra nếu
ai đó ném vào đó như phủ định một, phủ định hai, hoặc đại loại như vậy.
Vỏ cơ sở của bạn sau đó thoát ra khỏi đúng, và sau đó là bạn.
Tôi không biết chuyện này sẽ ra sao.
Nó chỉ sẽ tái diễn vô hạn bởi vì bạn sẽ thêm
âm một đến âm hai, âm ba đến âm bốn.
Và nó sẽ tái diễn vào quên lãng, phải không?
Vì vậy, đó là lý do tại sao bạn muốn làm những việc như thế này,
nơi mà nó khá hung hãn về việc trường hợp cơ sở của bạn sẽ như thế nào.
Vì bạn muốn bảo vệ mình chống lại bạn, chính bạn hoặc người khác, phải không?
Vì ai đó vào một lúc nào đó sẽ gọi Fibonacci bằng giá trị âm, và
thì toàn bộ chương trình của bạn sẽ nổ tung.
>> Brian Holt: Được rồi, vì vậy nếu nó nhỏ hơn hoặc
bằng hai thì bạn chỉ trả lại một, phải không?
Đó là cái đã cho.
Ngược lại, chúng ta sẽ trả về Fibonacci của n -1 cộng với n của fibonacci của n- 2.
Điều đó cảm thấy, ít nhất là đối với tôi, nó trông rất đẹp,
nó được viết rất tốt và nó khá rõ ràng về những gì nó đang làm, phải không?
Bạn chỉ là một người hàng đầu.
Nếu tôi có fibonacci (n), nó được định nghĩa là fibonacci (n-
1) + fibonacci (n- 2), nó hoạt động tốt.
Vâng, những thứ khá thú vị.
Tuy nhiên, hãy nói về lý do tại sao điều này thực sự là một loại điên rồ.
[LAUGH] Chà, quay lại bảng điều khiển của chúng ta ở đây.
Đi xuống đây là con số 6765, phải không?
Đó là một con số khổng lồ.
Bạn phải nghĩ về những gì đang thực sự xảy ra bên dưới chiếc mũ trùm ở đây.
Chúng tôi thực sự thêm một vì mọi thứ khác chỉ kết thúc là một.
Chúng tôi không có giá trị nào lớn hơn bắt đầu lớn hơn một, vì vậy
điều đó nói rằng để đạt được con số này, chúng tôi đã thêm 1 vào chính nó, 6.765 lần.
Cách nào không phải là cách hiệu quả nhất để tính ra một số, phải không?
Vì vậy, đó là lý do tại sao giải pháp này thực sự tệ vì
chúng ta đã gọi hàm ít nhất 6,765 lần, phải không?
Vì vậy, mặc dù điều này rất thanh lịch và hoạt động rất tốt cho
vấn đề này rất dễ đọc, bạn thực sự có thể trong trường hợp cụ thể này.
Nếu đó là một nút thắt cổ chai cho bạn, bạn thực sự có thể muốn viết điều này bằng cách sử dụng
vòng lặp và phiên bản vòng lặp của điều này là thô và khó chịu.
Ý tôi là, dù sao thì nó chắc chắn không phải là trang nhã.
Nhưng trong mọi trường hợp,
đó là cách bạn sẽ giải quyết vấn đề này vốn có lợi cho phép đệ quy.
Và hãy xem, đây là những đánh đổi mà bạn cần phải thực hiện trong đầu, giống như,
Tôi có đủ khả năng để có mã thanh lịch ở đây, phải không.
Bởi vì nếu bạn gọi điều này một lần một ngày thì cái quái gì vậy,
thêm số của bạn nhiều lần và gọi nó là tốt.
Nhưng nếu điều này được thực hiện với mọi yêu cầu của người dùng thì giống như,
bạn có thể muốn sử dụng vòng lặp hoặc lặp lại cho điều đó.
Có câu hỏi nào không?
>> Người nói 2: Được rồi, [COUGH] chữ O lớn trên cái này là gì?
>> Brian Holt: Có lẽ sẽ là Big O trong cái này.
>> Brian Holt: Bạn phải trải qua mọi thứ ít nhất một lần
>> Brian Holt: Và đăng nhập,
Tôi đoán, tôi thực sự không biết.
Vì vậy, đó là một câu hỏi phỏng đoán nhưng hay.
>> Người nói 3: Còn một câu hỏi nữa, bạn có thể giải thích cách hoạt động của hàm WR không?
>> Brian Holt: Chắc chắn rồi, từ giá trị dịch chuyển, được chứ?
WR, đây là một số phép thuật của ES6.
Được rồi, đây là một hàm mũi tên.
Hàm mũi tên chỉ là một cách khác để viết một hàm trong JavaScript.
Đây là một tham số mặc định.
Có lẽ sẽ hữu ích nếu chỉ viết cái này.
>> Brian Holt: Vì vậy, một cách khác để viết một hàm, phải không?
Đây là một tham số mặc định, nó cho biết nếu bạn không được cung cấp bất cứ thứ gì cho
điều này sau đó có một tham số mặc định.
Vì vậy, một cách để làm điều đó là nếu tôi không nhận được gì từ tin nhắn,
thì tin nhắn tương đương với điều đó, phải không?
Bất kể tôi đặt bao nhiêu.
Và sau đó nói ngay tại đây,
là document.write.
Đây là một chuỗi mẫu ES6,
mà nếu ai đó đã từng viết trước cú pháp đó sẽ trông quen thuộc với bạn.
Về cơ bản, nó nói thay thế cái này ở đây hoặc
bạn chỉ có thể làm br cộng với tin nhắn.
Đó cũng là điều tương tự.
Vì vậy, đây là phiên bản ES5 của điều đó.
Giờ độc thân cũng tương đương.
Vì vậy, câu hỏi hay.
>> Người nói 4: Về mặt kỹ thuật, bạn đang trả lại tài liệu, phải không?
>> Brian Holt: Vâng, đây là một sự trở lại ngầm.
Tôi có nghĩa là tôi có thể làm điều này và nó không phải là một sự trở lại ngầm.
Trong trường hợp này, nó không quan trọng vì tôi không quan tâm những gì nó trả về.
Nhưng nếu bạn bỏ dấu ngoặc nhọn trong một hàm mũi tên,
đó là một sự trở lại ngầm.
>> Brian Holt: Chúng tôi đã đánh cắp cái này từ CoffeeScript.
Không phải là một người hâm mộ CoffeeScript lớn, nhưng điều này hóa ra ổn.
Vì vậy, cảm ơn, CoffeeScript.